celebrities always clash over President
Trump first up Kanye West defending his
support of the president the rapper and
fashion designer delivering a message to
Trump critics on Jimmy Kimmel last night
here's Yeezy Unplugged just as a
musician african-american guy out in
Hollywood all these different things you
know everyone around me tried to pick my
candidate for me mm-hmm and then told me
every time I said I like Trump that I
couldn't say it out loud or my career
would be over
I get kicked out the black community
liberals can't believe me and news can't
bully me the hip-hop community they
can't believe me we're always you know
pushing out so much hate and love can
cure so much and when I see people just
even like go at the president it's like
why not try love
there we go why not try love meanwhile
Michael Moore's spewing more anti-trump
hate the liberal filmmaker dreams of
taking down the president in his new
documentary how did this happen
the American Dream is dead stop
resisting
the President's powers here are beyond
collection
ladies and gentlemen the last President
of the United States
oh so dramatic
Gregg I will go to you first we'll talk
about Kanye in a little bit but this
Michael Moore thing I feel like we've
been to this pony ride at the carnival
before yes and we've seen other people
say that single-handedly their piece of
work is going to be the thing that takes
down the president yo you couldn't have
the opposite effect well first of all
okay so he's acting like this has never
happened before this is not a new
Michael Moore okay he hated Bush if you
don't remember that he also hates he
hated every Republican he went after he
went who went after Charlton Heston
waging war on a conservative for him is
like eating three pizzas it's a daily
thing so I don't but I don't find I do I
guess I'm not excited or shocked by his
by his outrage but what's interesting to
me and maybe I said this before
Hollywood has replaced climate change
with Trump change because remember how
they climate change what caused
everything bad now Trump change is
causing everything bad probably
including ironically climate change no
actually because you they actually have
evidence now yes well Michael Moore was
the one who wanted that president Trump
was going to win right
and he said based on the people that I
talked to based on the part of the
country that I am from you are ignoring
these people the only one who was paying
attention was Bill Clinton we're
conservatives are good for business but
if you're in Hollywood right so Michael
Moore doesn't make great movies when
there's Democrats in office he makes
movies that make a lot of money when
conservatives are in office so I don't
think he's complaining that he has this
popularity now I don't think it really
believes the president Trump is the last
president of the United States he's an
entertainer and it's not very
entertaining
let's let's talk about Kanye a little
bit because I thought this was
fascinating interview with Jimmy Kimmel
Jimmy really tried to press and shame
him particularly about race and Kanye
said I'm not going to be bullied do you
think that he is just trolling or does
he really believe what he's talking
about
and carne blizzard is talking about I
mean I think katakana is entitled to his
thoughts he's entitled to his opinions I
doesn't think he's entitled to change
facts so I mean the reason why Kanye's
sort of come to this famous because he
said slavery was a choice and most
historians like no it wasn't a choice
and there was actually slave rebellions
but you know what he meant
metaphorically about there's no ideas
there are two ideas I think he was
talking about ideas no he tried to try
to walk it back by saying ideals but he
straight-up said slavery seems like a
choice to me and it wasn't and I think
this I deal with it this it's not about
ideals I think he was very clear and
when he said it and in the TMZ interview
and then he doubled down on and I think
history was talking about ideas but we
can agree to disagree we can present
Trump a greater service Michael Moore
with his propaganda or Kanye West with
his endorsement well let's get out of
the way first if Michael Moore is a
complete total hypocrite you know we
have Donald Trump is precisely because
of frauds like Michael Moore I mean did
I say that clear enough this guy is a
total fraud Flint Michigan which he
focuses on as his material for some of
his movies has been run by Democrats and
liberals since before I was born in 1974
so I don't understand he focuses is no
that's true no but the reason the reason
why Flint Michigan's the focus of this
documentary is because the water was and
dump them in that's not sure like that
you got suckered by that is you should
get run by Democrats decided not to buy
their municipal water Richard you don't
get to make up your own facts like I am
not did not do that they decided to not
because they were bankrupt because they
had no money decided not to buy their
water from Detroit to save money they
bought it from the river water Democrats
have known that City for this is a messy
that I was a dead at the other point
wasn't there something that just came
out about about the water not being
review and it was amazing that it didn't
get more attention but it's sort of like
Corrections don't get a lot of attention
in the press but it was that there
wasn't led in the water yeah I mean
there's they it's kind of if you see I
mean I look the leftovers in the water
what happened was it was the the city
with the the Flint water was taken over
by an emergency
Giordano early who also ran Detroit
Public Schools the the lead wasn't in
the water they stopped the treatment
that was used to stop the pipes from
decaying and the lab was actually in the
pipes and the pipes of a poisoned the
people but they were poisoned by an
emergency manager appointed by Rick by
Rick Schneider the governor all right
there's more dangerous Kanye West or the
flint pipes the Flint pipes listen Kanye
this is a necessary conversation yeah I
mean seriously why is it isn't it the
very essence of racism to suggest that
the melanin component of your skin Pro
precludes you from making independent
this is independent this is my politics
so Kayne West is not allowed to say we
keep him white he said in that clip he's
not political he's not even allowed to
say he likes and appreciates Donald
Trump without being accused of being
some kind of a sellout it is what you're
seeing and what he he talks about how
he's basically freeing himself he's he's
untethered to other people's assumptions
about him and it's cut it is we have to
admit it is a spectacle because he is
probably the world's biggest pop star I
mean imagine the 1950s if Elvis declared
himself a communist this is kind of
lords' happening it's like he's coming
out as a capitalist eight number one
albums debut at number one like Kanye
West I mean he really is a cultural
force and that's what makes it so
interesting because he has an
irrefutable argument you know and and
the argument is don't tell me how to
vote don't tell me how to think I like
this person because I like this person
do not put me in this monolith and just
last week we saw Kamala Harris try and
do that with identity politics at
Netroots nation yeah yeah I actually I
have a little note but post-it note it
says intellectual independence and I
just have it on my computer I've had it
there for years because how do you fit
that on a post-it note you have to write
really small independent I would not be
able to get that I posted I'm sorry it
is it's one of the best things about
living in a free country yes that you
get to make these decisions and you get
to say things that you want and there
aren't consequences for it except for
perhaps peer pressure
or criticisms or whatever it might be
but he's you know he's happy to take
them does Michael Moore still have
enough gas left in his bag in order to
fuel another meteoric documentary I
don't know we'll have to see how the
movie sells do I actually Fahrenheit
9/11 and by the way the title for this
film very lazy who was the PR person
listen here's the thing Michael Moore
gives fuel I mean he empowers Democrats
he gives Co to Republicans just like
Sarah Palin empowers Republicans gives
fuels to Democrats it's the same I like
the title that was pretty clever he
flipped it I didn't know that that was
yeah I just figured that out I'm a
little slow today over two hundred
million dollars at the box office now
its Fahrenheit eleven nine we have the
data the day after yes you know it's the
the first day of the last presidency
ever very sad just like just one point
of Kanye's we were in the green room and
we were talking about how on Twitter
people they do means they're constantly
imitating each other so somebody does
this thing that everybody this is
everybody tends to just do the same
thing with memes and with catchphrases
this is what happens when you don't do
it right the mob turns on you this is an
interesting example of somebody what
happens to people which is you know when
we talk about Christ when somebody steps
away from the crowd the mob turns on him
and I think it's it that's part of this
story that's often overlooked you know
what's really interesting though and
Greg brings up a good point we see the
same kind of revolt in the me to
movement if you have someone who comes
forward and questions the intentions of
the mob and not necessarily an accuser
or someone who is accused they're really
cannibalized I mean there there has to
be this cultural purity when it comes to
these or divisive issues or if you are
asked to get on board defending somebody
against an accusation and you don't do
it and there's a mob that happens that
way - yes absolutely I think you're
right Greg I think that there is a mob
mentality and I think it exists on both
sides of the aisle think of somebody
like John McCain who got like because he
disagree the president Lisa Staton
people like oh he's not a Republican
more he's a pariah now and you're like
John McCain's not a right now but that's
the argument you hear from Trump people
or like oh he's a rhino because he
disagreed with the president it's a flaw
among
it's really interesting though because
you know we and we do see sort of a
backlash and I think their most
effective when they're at least humorous
there was a group in Los Angeles called
the faction and they took dozens of
vinyl squares that are essentially
flooring vinyl with Donald Trump's star
in the middle and glued them to the
sidewalk as a way of saying if you take
his star away 30 more will pop up the
next day and it was it was a very
humorous piece of performance art you
know yeah I love that story but you know
on Kanye the I don't understand like
what what is the the whole the Democrat
Party has over the black community where
a successful young male black
entrepreneur there's no questioning that
no reasonable person would question that
he has managed to make a lot of money
and he's very successful a lot of people
that he can't he didn't even say
anything offensive I mean he said I'm
not really political I just like Trump
and I'll say it and I've been a you know
someone told me I'd be thrown out of the
black community I mean is that even
reasonable to a rational person this is
some surd this is way past time for the
conversation and Trump's approvals up to
in the black community the one thing
about that when you brought up the
stickers yeah I think it's it's it's a
it's a clarifying moment in the sense
that you're seeing a shift it's now kind
of the people the non liberals who are
actually having fun and being clever
this is a very merry prankster move with
this with with this these artists and it
was a conservative artist which is like
mind-blowing but I mean it's like you
think about you think about Andrew
Breitbart his inspiration and old red
eye and podcasters and we're going to
talk about Ben Shapiro later but it's
like that's what's happening you're
seeing a move which I think is
refreshing